oh this is the honest trailer commentary
you've been waiting for for the greatest
showmen we're gonna be talking about the
honest trailer that you hopefully just
watched and then come back here to check
out our thoughts our behind the scenes
stuff and if you stick around some
deleted scenes and song I think we have
an entire deleted song we do have a cut
song didn't make the cut yeah yeah so
before we all watch it together general
thoughts and feelings about the greatest
showmen well I'm gonna casually remove
my headphones that I put on way too
early and tell you that yeah this movie
is kind of just pure frosting and that's
pretty good and then you have a headache
I guess afterwards so yeah I mean it's
good soundtrack I take a lot of moral
issues with just taking a bad person
just completely glossing over and I'm
being like he's great he's bad for
bringing too much joy to children right
yeah yeah yeah when was the last time
you guys smiled but you know it's a very
fun flashy bright movie that I'm nervous
to say anything bad about cuz my wife
adores it
ah this is super Dorne oh well Dan your
thoughts first well we're off and I saw
this movie before it came out before it
became the phenomenon that it became and
both of us thought it was super weird
and we both gave it not a great review
not a terrible review but we didn't
recommend it and it was like you know
it's kind of like how when you talk
about Star Wars or a big movie and
you're critical you know that you're
stepping in front of a train sure this
was like stepping in front of a train
but it was behind you because as soon as
it came out we just got flattened and
just we're joyless we don't know how to
have fun or sin it's everything that
they said about the critic in them yeah
oh yeah they said about us I still think
this movie is super weird I don't know I
don't think it's terrible I didn't love
it but it's but a lot of people love it
and that's great that's great for that
I'm glad that people enjoy this movie it
brought a lot enjoyed a lot of people
didn't I thought it was interesting and
strange and odd and it didn't quite work
for me but what people were not happy
Ross and I were thinking is great the
editing is really cool the editor almost
becomes the choreographer for the songs
which i think is very cool looking but
uh yeah the guys it's a musical and
musicals like this especially have
played by different rules you judge them
based on whether you a woman between 16
and 45 or a man who just likes musicals
as I do myself likes to roll up the
windows and just like crank up the
soundtrack and belt it and the number of
crank able belt able songs in this is
like pushing no no six seven times the
even 11 maybe even 11 of songs you can
just like really really like throw out
there I think that might be what I took
the biggest hit on this is again when I
when I saw this movie there's no hype or
anything on it and the this is me really
stood out to me but in general I
described this I made a huge mistake
no I'm describing the songs as kind of
forgettable and oh my god yeah because
what people like like if you take the
music out of a musical it like what's
Katz it's like literally just people and
dumb Cosby sweatpants people like these
things because they like the songs I
like the songs a little better the
second time that I saw I didn't think
they were bad I just felt that they were
all kind of it's it was very very
dissonant to me like I just didn't I
wasn't prepared for this movie when I
saw it and I'm not backing off my baby I
still think it's weird and just kind of
odd and it doesn't really do a lot for
me still but you have to understand like
what it's like seeing this movie in a
void having heard nothing about it and
then it's the bearded lady's doing a
solo and Hugh Jackman's dancing around
with elephants it's very odd very odd
film no one actually has completed
storyline yeah I don't know it's you
know I'm glad that people enjoy it I'm
really I'm very happy that it did so we
I think people are yearning for a little
bit of cotton candy these days for a
little bit popcorn a little bit fluff
and this one does make you work too hard
for it doesn't make you think too hard
it just serves it up right for you on a
fish let's watch our skewering
[Laughter]
and an age were average comic-book
movies make tons of money and average
sequels rake in the dough theater nerds
finally get something average to blow
their wads on to the greatest showman
from the musical geniuses behind lala
land and dear Evan Hanson comes a film
to control your souls and catchy hits
just begging for an overly sincere
YouTube cover video pause and just
looking into this film like that was she
spoke of the Train and coming up to
smash in the neck the movie the
multiplier you're like the stats kept
getting it was like the biggest one ever
because it opened poorly and just made
more and more and more and more money
now they I think it was right around
when the film released they had
influencers yeah the I word YouTube
influencers cover the song from the film
and that supposedly was like the little
spark that lit the flame that burned
down the first order it has the staying
power of like Avatar Titanic I mean the
the the staying power that that thing
and then the amount of growth that it
showed in the amount of D created there
were weekends where it gained yeah it
gained I wish I could have seen Hugh
Jackman take that phone call like after
the first weekend when he's like another
flop or whatever and then that second
weekend they're like huge huge yeah
because that doesn't happen but yeah
they were really smart with the with the
influencer marketing campaign I mean
there were literally they did like a we
are the world style thing with YouTube
singers from all over the place to sing
all the songs with the cast and they
played this real smart you can get teens
on board they see it more than once oh
yeah and a lot of free time I feel like
when I said that I wasn't crazy about
the movie they think I say that I hated
the message which I don't that's a very
nice message
I just can't separate the two I I
enjoyed the message then why are you a
monster
there's a little thing called nuance
well whatever I've tried I've tried it
before it's not in that no-man's land
it's not in the internet yeah let's keep
watching video
as you still find a nine teen friendly
jams wrapped in a story that will make
you wonder when is the next song start
the bank they're evicting us I'm still
not here for the talky bits that's
better
me PT Barnum the boy who grew from
wishing he owned his own top hat
to the man who owned all the top hats
play as so many top hats even before he
strikes it rich I think I might be why
his lifelong dream to open a weird
murder Museum when that doesn't pan out
he'll roll with his backup plan a scam
freak show paid for by fraud that he
abandons his wife and kids for he calls
the free society but after a series of
show-stopping musical numbers this
social-climbing conman will be met with
lifelong success and happiness maybe you
are fraud maybe it was just about making
a buck Oh throw to you quick do a hat
trick that is the key thing is this is
the story of PT Barnum but it is not and
again this is an interesting question of
I should have should if a movie is about
a person should the fact that it has
nothing true at all play into your
opinion of the movie and there is
everyone that I talked to said no
everyone that yet that that sent me
comments said who cares if it's not
about the person I think if there's a
little bit you should take into
consideration I mean it's a little scary
my first thought watching this for the
trailer was I started my first like run
if you will that I was playing with was
like the idea of like well floodgates
are open here are other like troubling
fictional character of real-life
characters that we can just start really
glossing up and talked about all the
wonderful things that they did but I
kept waiting in this movie for him to
learn his lesson because he is he's like
hey you're a freak come make some money
you might as well get paid and clearly
you know takes advantage of all of these
people and they sort of go A to C and
skip be like at no point is he like oh
man not only did I use all of you for
money and then drop you the moment I got
to join high society
but then they're just like you know what
you're great and there's never a moment
where he like learns at least do that I
think it was a missed opportunity
because he didn't have to fully I get
not like showing the time when he
autopsy his slave for money for people
which is a real thing did 100% true
elderly woman he held a public autopsy
don't need to do that but you can still
do
he was later on like a governor or some
kind of political candidate and he
campaign as an abolitionist so you could
like do some kind of character growth or
some cut and his relationship with Tom
Thumb was actually really interesting it
was like a love/hate thing they were
really close even though he was taking
advantage of him I just maybe the maybe
the movie should have been from the
perspective of his performers and not
him
maybe that would be a yeah or if he or
if it was a two-hander with him and Tom
Thumb or something like that yeah that's
very nuanced Spencer now there's no new
watts of PT Barnum and there's no new
room for new what's with this movie all
right he was great and it was great he
was great it was great
there's just no I don't know like Zac
Efron and zendaya make eye contact and
smile and don't do anything else and
then hold hands and then break up like
there's no in-betweens for anyone in
this movie is an especially not for PT
Barnum that made me feel feel a little
weird I kept expecting Zac Efron to be
Bailey you guys hear about Barnum &
Bailey oh yeah yes your spell yeah
Bailey well the circus thing didn't
happened to way later yeah way m60 way
after he didn't have an affair and way
after he didn't do a lot of the things
in this movie
that's the post-credits scene yeah the
circus came much later in his life but
you know it's but I kept thinking like
okay but I mean they didn't even cheat
it's like Zac Efron is totally fictional
right like not even based on anybody but
I thought that in my mind I was like I
mean again whatever but it's like if
you're gonna like at least make a Bailey
if you're gonna play with everything
else like it just seemed curious that
they didn't at least okay its Bailey
it's historically inaccurate but who
cares okay yeah I was waiting for that
moment where he's like I need a showy
name to and then
some somebody's like daily Bail Bonds
here and he's like yeah because the only
time we see him working for with someone
else
aside from Zac Efron is when he's
working for like a shipping company he's
like a like a clerk or something like
that yeah and they're like we lost a
shipment we're bankrupt everything so
like he works for the worst shipping
company with no insurance and no backup
plan if one ship goes down and be like
that company's down sorry guys sorry
guys sorry boys I also didn't understand
what he hired Zeca fron for was it just
to get into like I don't know what his
job was ticket to the top got it
okay nuance it ain't alright let's keep
going
a trick witness this real-life Willy
Wonka but instead of selling kids candy
he selling kids tickets to laugh at the
Oompa Loompas where the tragedy of these
people's exploitation is brushed aside
laughing anyway consumer might as well
get paid to spend more time with to
perfect physical specimens feast your
eyes on a forbidden romance subplot
where Zac Efron is rich and white but
zendaya is poor and usually a body
double
and while the circus performers have to
live with being literally beaten in the
streets Efron and PT will get way more
sympathy for having food snobby parents
have been a real villains thank you
well if I say the face this is a
masterstroke when you make a movie like
this to put a critic character in it so
that in the movie you can say by the way
if you don't like my show this you don't
know how to have fun do you yes when was
the last time you smiled yes like I love
even the critic that didn't like the
show at the end of it like begrudgingly
one could say
just like so not only saying that if you
don't like the show that you don't have
no have fun secretly you like it anyway
it's it's like the opposite of me just
one of the clicks it's like the opposite
of calling Kritika Disney show yeah
which never happens but it's just like
you know you didn't like it just admit
it it's the opposite of that again savvy
move that was a very peaty Hugh Jackman
that was a very PT Barnum move to put a
character in your movie that's a critic
so that you can tell critics this
healthy audience this is reduce our my
stupid and cynical we have a whole
deleted a run about that so so stick
around today that was a very Barnum move
it's very the whole movies very meta
very sad thing about so let's keep going
so march to the beat of your own drum
with this upbeat inspiring musical about
a really shady cruel historical figure
but since too much honesty doesn't sell
we've got you covered with a more
accurate PT Barnum musical with songs
like the he wasn't a good guy saw
ladies and gents I'm not a guy that's
what cheering for yeah well first of all
yes he killed six whales you kill six
whales you of here's what happened yeah
I read about those yeah four of them he
was trying to get the salt content
correct in the tank and it didn't work
cool and it was such a running gag like
when he replaced I think the first set
of whales
he literally advertises like come see
them while they're alive oh no they're
gonna die and then two of them there
actually was a there were several fires
his circus burned down for over the
museum three or four different times two
of them just were boiled alive it's just
not funny so I I believe in the notes
III sent dispenser I wrote that he
killed at least six that we know that we
know of and then you owned a slave it
was the the George wash and it was
tortures and got around anti-slavery
laws by leasing her yes for a set amount
of money but it was got the autopsy
right yeah yes and then she said he said
that she was 160 years old and then when
she died he performed a public autopsy
to prove that he himself was a liar and
that she was only eight years old so he
held a public spectacle to disprove the
lie that he himself had told about the
nice I bet I bet he was like one of
those lying critics said she was 160 and
I bought it one of those cynical critics
with what's fascinating there's a sucker
born every minute attributed to him no
one no one knows that if he ever said
that just so probably was not him his
most famous quote Buncombe Buncombe pure
Buncombe I say let's keep watching yeah
[Music]
that's his mermaid the Fiji mermaid
the made-up affair saw and she gets
Jenny lens really gonna put dragged
through the mud hole portrayed is a
homewrecker
[Music]
she was basically like
Oprah and Adele and they turned her into
like yeah
saucy minx
[ __ ]
[Music]
the these tempos again it's a yes that's
technically not part of the movie
quote-unquote but that is pretty like
that is some huge Liberty with somebody
to take someone who by all accounts is
very talented person had a very
successful to both of their immense
advantage and then to make this move
just like but she was a homewrecker yeah
like you know she was she was thirsty
for the D and the Furious when he said
no yeah she got him back yeah this was a
really pretty amazing like she took all
that money and like open to music school
for girls like she was a pretty cool get
it it's like yeah that does any to do
this movie though like I understand but
like kid we just objectively say that
that's kind of screwed up yeah there
will be like there will be people who I
mean look I think people who take this
movie as 100% fact will probably never
think about Jenny Lind again in their
lives
buddy Lynch she was that homewrecker
yeah like she went that's that's the
history is that she was yeah this weird
scarlet haired scarlet lady
yeah I'm just thinking like what is the
the is there a expiration date on
reality yeah because it's like yeah
apparently yeah because I'm thinking
about like Titanic like yeah that was
like an actual tragedy where hundreds of
people died but it's maybe a hundred I
don't know but it's more than a hundred
yeah but all anyone now knows about
Titanic is is Leo but but Titanic except
for that one dude who they said killed
himself who didn't that's speaking of
messed up things to do someone's legacy
that guy who was portrayed as a coward
who murdered convinced ooh aside also
not true other than that which is a big
asterisk
was pretty held the legacy of the actual
people fairly well and a greatest
showman take on Titanic would be that
Jack swam under the boat push it back up
to the surface
then everyone just gave a standing O
while the two of them just banged in
that car again and then captain Smith's
shot him in the head yeah yeah that one
guy though he really he really took the
brunt at least even Billy Zane they had
them at the yeah the goal to at least
the decency to make him up but I think
this is actually the truest to the
legacy of PT Barnum by making a complete
propaganda musical celebrating how great
it was very Bardem s ferry Barnes true
great PT Barnum yeah let's keep going
these two people didn't even exist song
speaks of Jack and Rose
[Music]
[Applause]
good cast and the rabbit cruelty saw
[Music]
pause you may recognize the dulcet tones
of Joestar and myself and and other
people we found around the office who
graciously lended their voices Matt
Citroen did the did the music and did a
great job on everything but this one
just lacked like a little oomph
so we basically more we basically forced
press-ganged our producer max kind of
press-ganged anyone with a choice to get
into a Roth is and there she was not
thrilled to be there our production
coordinator Tina yeah I was going to do
it but and I did not make this up guys I
swear I've had some dentistry done and
right when we're about to record I had I
had a little residual stuff it's I
couldn't do it do you think when idina
menzel dazeem has dentistry done that
the show doesn't go on
well I'm no Adele no star course in
there thank you to the defi video course
to our parody song of this is me more
important than anything else oh did yes
Aska
[Music]
see the guy with no arms and legs that
he kept in a cage
funny story
Hugh jazz hands young man Logan a
disapproving wife character a
disapproving critic character old school
Music Hall can she swing from a thread
take a look overhead span Reggie
lip-sync impossible Harry Elsa jerk du
Soleil level you can Barnum an elephant
never forgets don't worry they're all
CGI elephant yeah let's not make him
wait let's see what else we cut delete
it see it wasn't good enough strap in
for this meta tale about show business
were a slop jockey placed to the lowest
common denominator gets rewarded with
tons of cash and proves how irrelevant
critics are creamy gravy circus I like
circus just look at this movie out in
the real world was pure cotton candy
escapism that dominated the box office
and will do just fine no matter how many
snarky little criticisms we throw at it
was the last time you smile so so long
ago buzz his marriage that's true I mean
look yeah even if the movie was in our
cup of tea it's just fine it'll do fine
Hugh Jackman's doing great I did the
movie wins the studio with studio wins
everyone wins yes yeah
yeah we're just haters Here I am looking
like a like a smug joyless son of a
[ __ ] but I was just like the cry and I
don't know how much I speak for table I
really like the music and songs awesome
the rest of it I don't care for on
second second listen it grew on me a bet
I can say yeah but yeah it's you know
don't wash this this guy's a piece of
anyways he was a complicated it's
complicated in this movie would have you
believe it anyways let's go his marriage
didn't go like that song
[Music]
you can take a coffee break
yeah they had this whole like laws that
he met her while he was like helping his
dad be it Taylor and she was getting
sippy cup lessons like they were that
young when they were like that's my wife
that's my husband and they wrote to each
other they met when they were I mean
they were still like 1921 they were
middle-aged and they got married and she
died many remarried like instantly so
you know break old man show man and PU
bunk up huge as man fan he sings all
then he'll singing all van he'll dancing
no force buddies you Siskel and Ebert
will crap I like Zac Efron now
the chap in the Hat oh sure now you care
when they're literally on fire
whales boiling in there running back in
to save was the I want the end of that
movie should have been him take him in
the weird furry ninja guy which the
movie slept on that guy by the way when
the big fight happens inside the circus
and all of a sudden the big dog man is
just doing like triple flips and jump
kicking people I what what's happening
Wolverines like I can call beast hold on
I'm pretty sure did the Black Widow
headscissors yeah
yeah that was them at school it
should've been their story they should
have been a that gang and then the like
weird relationship they had with Petey
and like they you know they had a they
had a path and Petey just kind of stayed
the same you know
right pecan AC like he would have been
much more of a PT Barnum type like yes
you're charming but you seem a little
sleazy - okay everybody's laughing why
not just get paid it's against the law
to touch the freaks y'alls whistles
ain't went after the bearded lady I'll
take my shirt off anyways
that's that that's that it's a we have
mixed feelings I think the movie got
mixed reception because we saw it as a
movie but if you look at it as a
soundtrack crank that crank it up and
crank that Soulja Boy just live out loud
yeah live your life yeah I'm gonna go
with in the corner with the writer from
house of cards smug little critics on
their own little that's right that was
him yeah yeah there's a weird role for
him you know we didn't get into that but
that was that was weird yeah he's been
fighting a lot of tortured tortured
people lately he's yeah we're capable of
smiling or enjoying things but I hope
you are I hope you were and I hope you
enjoyed and smile during this Australian
commentary so please come back next week
while we do we are gonna drive a lot of
traffic all right all right baby
you
[Music]